hey Leute na heute mal Urlaub in der
eigenen Stadt also quasi ich wollen wir
eigentlich ein Kreuzberg einen neuen
Perso beantragen aber ja Berliner
Verwaltung alle Termine 12 Wochen im
Voraus ausgebucht aber jetzt habe ich
einen heißen Tipp bekommen Bürgeramt
Berlin Spandau da kann ich morgen
zwischen 7 und 8 Uhr ohne Termin ja dann
würde ich natürlich nicht den Zufall
überlassen hat mir genau gegenüber ein
Zimmer gebucht und jetzt mache ich durch
ich habe alles da also hier äh Sandwich
Toaster klar und dann DVD Player alle
Filme von Hape Kerkeling werde ich jetzt
chronologisch durch gucken kommt man ja
so selten dazu aber vorher habe ich noch
genug Zeit mich über Bürokratie
aufzulegen es kann doch nicht sein dass
ich Monate darauf warten muss meinen
Perso zu beantragen um dann darauf zu
warten dass ich mehr abholen kann es war
auch 5 Monate bis ich so ein Ding habe
auf dem mein Name steht den ich ja schon
kenne nichts ist unbefriedigender als
knapp 40 Euro für ein Perso zu bezahlen
ein Ding das nur für andere ist quasi
ein Geschenk für die Polizei die noch
nicht mal darüber freut wenn ich es ihm
gebe ey wacht auf wir sind nicht in den
Achtzigern wir kennen jetzt
Online-Bestellung und das macht den
Unterschied der Geschwindigkeiten noch
sichtbarer wenn ich mir ein veganen
Donut bestellen will dann ist ja in 15
Minuten hier zack da wenn ich jetzt eine
sage ich mal
wurstkabeltrommel bestellen ist die
übermorgen da hä glaubte nicht
ausprobiert ja wurst Kabeltrommel ja
eine Kabeltrommel nur mit Wurst warum
ist es absurder ein Perso in Berlin
haben zu wollen als eine
wurstkabeltrommel etwas völlig sinnloses
kriege ich sofort aber wehe es geht um
was wichtiges in der idealen Welt wäre
der Person übermorgen da der Person
braucht ziemlich genau 150 Tage länger
als die Wurst Kabeltrommel und ja kann
sein dass ich etwas zu viel Spaß haben
an dem Wort wurstkabeltrommel ist
natürlich alles bestellt
verlieferdiensten bei dem wir wissen oh
der Artikel Arbeitsrecht ah der ist da
zur Zeit leider nicht verfügbar warum
klappt Geschwindigkeit nur so
ausbeutungsbasis und nicht bei dem
Personal unserer Demokratie und warum
habe ich Angst morgen an jemand super
unfreundliches zu geraten bei dem ich
das Gefühl bekomme meinen Job als Kunde
irgendwie nicht richtig zu machen ich
habe schon Ämter als gebrochener Mensch
verlassen also ich habe auch sehr nette
Leute in Verwaltung erlebt aber auch
extrem unfreundliche so sind Menschen
halt könnte man sagen ja absolut aber
als Bürger soll es ja nicht vom Glück
abhängen ob mir jemand das Formular
erklärt es ist Teil ihres Jobs voll
nicht zu sein ich erwarte ja nicht das
Annemarie danach zu mir du ich habe
heute Rouladen gemacht magst Du
vielleicht mit Essen ich erwarte nur
nicht mega unfreundliche Menschen auf
dem Abend weil sie verrückte Idee einen
Service Beruf haben die Flugbegleiterin
im Flugzeug kriegen auch nicht Geld weil
so toll Notausgänge zeigen können
sondern weil sie das Flugzeug nicht
anzünden wenn der Junggesellenabschied
zum 14 Mal Leila singt auf dem Amt gibt
es immer auch Menschen bei denen du
sofort merkst die langweilen sich seit
30 Jahren und ihre einzige Freude ist
dir zu sagen wie dumm du bist dass du
ihr Formular für die Anmeldung die
ausfüllen kannst warum kann ich nicht
bewerten so dass man bei 300 ein Sterne
Bewertung für manfre D mal nachfragt ob
er sich noch ganz wohl fühlt im Amt der
muss als Strafe sein Personal beantragen
in der Ausländerbehörde auf Englisch
weil bitte kannst kein Englisch Mann
keine Sorgen die Kollegen da könnte es
auch nicht und ja die dürfen dann auch
uns bewerten bei uns sind bestimmt auch
viele Assis als Kunden dabei ja aber
wenn du dich daneben benimmst musst du
einen Tag im Wartezimmer im Bärenkostüm
Luftballons aufblasen soll ich selber
mal anziehen und dann aufblasen okay ja
ist sehr witzig danke
klar viele Behörden Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter sind einfach belastet es ist
nur kacke es fehlen mehr als 300.000
Fachkräfte im öffentlichen Dienst das
sagt sogar das Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft also alle Arbeiten immer auch
ein bisschen mit für jemanden der gar
nicht da ist für jemanden Arbeiten der
nicht da ist ist ausschließlich okay in
der Kirche können wir das bitte ändern
damit es keinen Grund mehr gibt für
Unfreundlichkeit und vor allem damit wir
nicht mehr so langsam sind das ginge ja
auch schneller mit hoch
Digitalisierung warum kann ich das
Scheißding nicht online buchen warum
kann ich nicht per WhatsApp oder
telegram mal Mitarbeiter oder meiner
Mitarbeiterin schreiben Hallo hier ist
till hat wieder Person verloren sorry
noch mal bitte neuen schicken Online
Überweisung schon raus Adresse habt ihr
ja danke ich kann jedes fucking Auto
innerhalb von Minuten buchen die
kontrollieren sogar online mein
Führerschein aber wenn ich zum Bürgeramt
muss hast du ein Date mit dem büromuseum
gar nicht übertrieben es gibt eine hö
faxdichte auf Ämtern als im
Technikmuseum wie langsam Bürokratie ist
hat man besonders während Corona gemerkt
die Krankenkassen meinten es gäbe nicht
genug Papier für eine Impfpflicht und
mir geht es jetzt nicht um die
Impfpflicht sondern dass wir haben nicht
genug Papier ernsthaft ein Argument in
Deutschland sein kann ich möchte dass es
nur noch ein handschriftlich auszufüllen
des Formular gibt in Deutschland und
zwar für Behörden wenn sie begründen
müssen warum sie das nicht digital
machen und hört auf mit den
Scheinargumenten ja wir können es nicht
machen alles digital nee was mit alten
Leuten was ist mit denen die kein Handy
haben oder Internet nicht können aus
irgendwelchen Gründen ja die können ja
immer noch aufs Amt gehen und lassen
sich von freundlichen Menschen helfen
die haben dafür dann nämlich Zeit weil
80% jetzt ihren Scheiß von zu Hause
ausmachen kann danke
wie was ist nee er macht jetzt hier alle
Pause wegen Arbeitsrecht jetzt oder was
habe ich so daher gesagt jetzt doch
nicht hier Arbeitsrecht ich habe gerade
angefangen mich aufzuhören richtig viele
Pet so ja mach mal zwei gut dann machen
wir gut machen wir zwei Teil alles klar
ihr könnt in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
raten wie viel Papier produziert werden
muss wenn man drei Windräder aufstellen
will könnt ihr jetzt hier direkt runter
kommentieren einfach mal an wie viel
Papier braucht man so und wir sehen uns
dann Teil 2